all today on how to be a man you got the
whole world in your balls and now what
okay a big swinging dick okay and this
is this is how you got SNL strap in and
get ready for a non-stop thrill ride of
man's flow civ proportions
this is jacuzzis how to be a man here's
Dave Koechner with how to be the best
all right you ready to be the best yes
Dave rule number one don't doubt
yourself okay I got it
can I do that again you want to do this
again you understand that little part
just no I just go as good it was guys it
was good right Amy cuz it didn't quite
come off like you're ready didn't I tell
you let's try it again
right again I hear this is uh I'll just
walk in okay be the best yes don't doubt
yourself
rule number one don't don't got yourself
this lip you know the other day liar
it seemed different like you I guess I
just having an off day that is that is
the day when you I really do need you to
bring it not on the phone when you're
wrong with Amy that's like is Amy here
oh hey you ready to be the best it say
to me I'm the most can the host be a
woman you don't want a me on camera
forget everything you've learned okay
I'm sorry what's your name I forgot
everything I learned Dave Koechner
what was that that's just like a little
it's like a joke cause almost on camera
hell yeah yeah you don't like jokes I
love jokes yeah well I just didn't know
you're gonna do that now I have to come
up with one I have to come up with one
well you you kids you gave me nothing
give me something reactive hey hey Dave
how's it how's it going how's it going
Colleen going why don't you beat it
Michael Jackson change number one mmm
you nailed it Dave you're damn right I
know man you hit man hey hey maybe
you're gonna be nailed next okay Oh what
what
well thanks Oh who's that that that is
Kevin if you believe paternity tests
yeah
only 17 Dave traveled 16 hours on a
greyhound from Illinois just to be here
just just to meet yeah yeah you
shouldn't quit your job just any time
you ever want I just you know hang out
or talk let me know
come on anyway that's that this guy
coming begging for a dad
17 years later I know I mean it was a
mistake what does he look what does he
want you know food and shelter get out
of here hey what's what's Will Ferrel
like Dave Will Ferrell the best I knew
it I knew it I knew the fellow was great
that's a great dad
Will Ferrell - quick quick on the call
motion let's call whoa ha hey Kevin day
we might we might call Will Ferrell
later yeah we're not gonna call well
Jesus Kevin two drinks shut down today
well what is it do want me to be your
dad or do you want to meet welfare any
time you want to just share some wisdom
you're not my son
you'll never be my son if I had no
children I would still not want you as
my son Oh be in the other room
I believe this guy pretty good I gotta
remember that for a monologue
here's how a loser wakes up all right
uh-huh what we're are the Fritos man
I'll show you how I wake up okay I want
it I want more of it that was a great
dream I'm gonna live the dream I just
had
try it why don't you try a difference
you want me to try I want you to try it
close my eyes how you normally wake up I
feel silly it's okay actually it's a
lesson let's try it again I went too far
let's let's do a nice gentle wake up
here we go don't I want you to think of
the your your your fondest childhood
finish it for more awesome videos that
teach you how to be a man subscribe to
our YouTube channel and follow us on
Twitter
you